sur le front sud la ville de miku laïque
l'une des principales cibles de l'armée
russe parce qu'elle conduit justement
vers la ville portuaire et stratégiques
d'odessa gwendoline de bono et notre
envoyé spécial
nous sommes à l'entrée de la ville de
nicolet qui se situe environ à 100 km
après année ça c'est le dernier verrou
pour les forces russes sur la route
d'odessa c'est aussi une ville qui leur
permettrait bien de couper la route
entre odessa et kiev s'est donc une
cible stratégique pour les forces russes
qui ne sont pas encore entrés dans la
ville où nous nous sommes rendus les
forces ukrainienne etienne le terrain
pour l'instant les forces russes se
concentrent aux abords de la ville et là
nous avons rencontré plusieurs résidants
blessés à l'hôpital qui nous ont raconté
avoir vu des tanks russes des
hélicoptères qui nous ont raconté
comment et bien les soldats russes
rentrer dans les maisons pour notamment
trouver à manger à l'hôpital de nicolas
yves nous avons également rencontré
plusieurs soldats blessés qui ont été
visés leur base a été visée par un
missile russe plusieurs d'entre eux
plusieurs de leurs camarades sont morts
on voit donc que les forces russes
pousse vraiment vers cette ville de
nicolet yves que c'est une ville et
stratégique est très importante pour le
front sud résultat nous avons vu sur la
route et bien être des centaines
d'habitants en train d'essayer de
quitter la ville